the jurogan experience well that's what
i that's why i was so
like when nunes lost
like i almost couldn't believe what i
was seeing i was like yeah yeah because
i'm sitting there watching with other
people and i'm like and i and i and i
bet money on the on the poirier fight
who'd you bet on poor egg you bet on
puerto rico yeah cause i was like
there's no way he just came off that
the fights with khan connor i was like
there's no way he's gonna lose but but
but uh you know i'm not as big a fan as
so my homie is the one he's the joe
rogan in our group where he knows so
much does if anything i don't understand
he just explains it you know yeah
he was trying to tell me no man
oliveira's a [ __ ] monster and i'm
like oliver is a monster people think of
oliveira as not being a monster because
there's times that people have beaten
him like paul felder smashed him and
there's a lot of guys that beat him cub
swanson ko'd him guys have beaten him
but he got better and you gotta you
gotta you gotta accept that and not
think of like when he lost because so
many people well who gets better at 35
i'm like i don't believe he's 35 no no i
think he's younger than that and he's i
think he's 33 and i also think that he
got into the ufc when he was 20. and so
part of the problem was like he was
learning and developing and growing as
an elite in an elite organization how
old is he 32 oh okay wow
so see he's been around a long ass time
but he came into his own over the last
few years which kind of makes sense like
he figured it out somewhere around 27 28
but he comes look these guys are elite
right they come close to beating him but
he finds a way to beat them and the way
he does it is so final the way he beat
poirier man that choke was so [ __ ]
good
it was so good
and that's the same way the world found
out about him was freyan escudero who
won the ultimate fighter so he was a
very good fighter himself
he fought oliveira and oliveira took his
back same way standing up and choked him
out
and that's when we first saw him and the
first time i really i recognized him
like man this kid is talented and but
then it was like his jujitsu was really
good but maybe his striking wasn't as
good as jiu jitsu and then slowly his
jujitsu striking merged where he's like
equal in both of them he's lethal and
he's lethal and striking and lethal in
his jujitsu but the difference is his
level of jiu-jitsu is a
a leap higher than most of the people
he's competing against i didn't realize
that he has the most submissions in the
history of the ufc make sure that's true
yeah they're pretty sure that's true
that also blew me because they were
saying that during the broadcast yeah
that blows my mind but it's also like
everybody i'm always like
i'm always in my mind going
i want to see this guy fight could be oh
yes that would have been the fight and
maybe it could be maybe it could be
look maybe it could be still khabib
might decide at one point in time you
know okay charles oliveira holds the
record for the most submission wins with
a mind-boggling 14 wins click on that
because i think it's 15 now because i
think that might be a uh article that
was written the pre the before the poor
ea fight i think
i think ah doesn't matter um either way
oliveira holds the record and
it's the way he does it man there's it's
jiu-jitsu is a wild thing like there's
guys that are smaller than me and i'll
grapple with them and i'm in
deep danger from the moment it starts
with the moment you start sparring
because they're just so much better than
me they just had better and that's the
difference between oliveira and these
guys it's like they're all really good
standing up he's really good standing up
so there's kind of like an even playing
field but when that [ __ ] gets a
hold of you you're in deep danger
terrifying danger well you can't make
any mistakes oh yeah 15. see damn this
brain is like a steel trap
occasionally yeah and he's like yeah
it's like the timing could be but scary
that way where it's like yeah because
after that fight i went back and watched
like all all his highlights and all
because you know you hear that and it's
like yeah it's a there's a precision
there's a
there's a predator like
like precision where he pounces on the
like as soon as you give him an opening
yes it's a wrap